i know i want to get to daigo's question
but you just said i i please i have to
interject with one thought pascal in
your book you mentioned that he had
a quotation about
the whole point of reason i believe it
was reason not rationality but let's
imagine it's reason that the whole point
of reason is to realize that there's an
infinitude of more important aspects to
life than reason
and then i was wondering
well
what does one say to the
retort that
when giving and when giving a reason to
not use reason you're still appealing to
reason so it's somewhat self-defeating
how do you get out of that
um i didn't quite catch the meaning of
your last
okay let's say you're giving let's say
you're explaining to someone here's why
you shouldn't use reason alone or if
it's rationality alone but either way
you're giving away an argument
and giving a reason to well there are
different levels of reason
and there's a kind of meta level of
reason and i think the meta level the
overarching view that takes in both is
usually the one i would say is best
associated more likely to be associated
with the working of the right hemisphere
and so
as i say the right hemisphere is no
stranger to reason absolutely not
um
and
it would be a big mistake to say that it
in any way rejected it but it's more
likely to see the limits of it because
it's
it's able to stand outside of its own
viewpoint and see there are things that
it doesn't know which the left
hemisphere is very
bad at doing so it thinks i've got this
schema which will solve all my problems
i run them through
this mental computer and the solution
comes out which is the right answer
and the right temperature can say no
there could be many right answers that
are not you know they're not necessarily
compatible with one another but they
might apply in different circumstances
at different times with different people
so
to see a more nuanced and
more complex picture i think the right
hemisphere is the one that would be
using elements of reason and there's
nothing wrong with reason in itself to
show the limits of reason this is really
what pascal was saying
and you've just demonstrated that that
is that is okay
he made a distinction between what he
called
geometry geometers
and esprit fine spirits and he says the
fine spirits by the word fine he means
subtle
so the subtle spirit is different from
the
slightly bull in the china shop black
and white hard and fast
inflexible
geometric spirit in which he's saying
you know
you you you turn away you do a diagram
and you've you've got the answer whereas
the
the esp
he says can see things understand things
that can hardly be put into words but
are very very important now coming from
a mathematician that is a very in a very
great mathematician that's a very
important thing to hear